27 portraits de jeunes habitants de
vélizy sont exposées dans la commune et
à l'hôtel de ville depuis le 12 février
c'est long deux théâtres centres d'art
qui est à l'origine de cette exposition
et des par un photographe et une
graphiste
l'objectif c'est de mettre en avant à un
moment tout l'intérêt que nous portons
cette jeunesse qui aujourd'hui plus que
jamais est touché par la situation
sanitaire
touchés dans ces études dont deux
touchés dans ses relations amicales
touché dans ses relations sociales un
appareil le photographe a passé cinq ou
six semaines a immortalisé ces jeunes à
travers ses clichés
moi je trouvais que c'était important
d'inscrire l'ondh dans le portrait donc
j'ai fait des cadrages assez large avec
l'idée que le décor avait son importance
dans l'image il racontait aussi son
histoire la relation du jeune à londres
et en même temps comme c'est la jeunesse
je pense que c'était important pour moi
d'avoir les jeunes en pied c'est à dire
en fait que la posture et son importance
dans l'image aussi c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi sur les cadrages assez large
pour cette exposition le photographe a
travaillé avec anna trance une graphiste
on a travaillé chacun de notre côté mais
en se coordonnant pire que moi j'ai fait
mon travail de portraits avec les jeunes
et j'ai donné à anet le corpus d'image
terminée et retouchée mais avec des
cadrages suffisamment large pour qu'elle
puisse intervenir a surtout elle est là
elle a construit un décor avec les
lettres qu'elle a émis imaginé pour le
avec le prénom des jeunes qu'on a
photographié et j'ai cru que c'était une
super idée franchement moi je suis assez
content du résultat
l'exposition sera visible dans le hall
de la mairie de vélizy villacoublay
jusqu'au 30 avril